we made it off the boat and we are sad
you suggest oh my god really
[Music]
right it's our second last day meme is
excited a bunch of people's up the boat
already our family left the boat we
didn't get the chance to say goodbye
they have a shore excursion so we're
gonna pick up hayden and go see Miami oh
they're still here you're supposed to be
gone by now I can't get out the ship
without my card
hey look at Miami guys
[Music]
oh thank you since my first sausage how
the Froot Loops you're gonna miss it
when you go home no more fruit loop in
this back kanji and a bunch of bread and
an egg that's a lot of pride
[Music]
memories was it a good trip
good still one more day we are off the
boat we made it off the boat and we are
side side eight inside it's okay next
year we are walking to our Miami hotel
dumped off our baggage and then explore
this city
[Music]
someone's feeling comfortable you want
to stick here sleep in the lobby okay
that's your room
[Music]
all right check into hotel jumped off
our bags we're now I'm gonna pop into an
uber and hit some Miami Beach
start off on Lincoln Road Mall which is
a pedestrian area shopping place and
then head down Ocean Drive check out the
beach and that's gonna be our day coffee
in Starbucks we need
[Music]
so we're on Lincoln Road this is a
pedestrian area only full of different
shops pretty famous here in Miami Beach
and we're gonna check it out
[Music]
are we fine for Nina's Oh
Nina's not very happy she hasn't had her
Starbucks you'll see a much happier Nina
after the Starbucks caffeine that she's
kangri it's coffee angry angry
definitely kangri
they have a horchata almond milk from
Pacino never heard of that before us
we're gonna give him a shot how is it
my copter tastes like oatmeal what you
said yes oh my god really
[Music]
my horchata very sad tastes like oatmeal
okay I'm gonna chew them
[Music]
I'm a dud it's like cinnamon oatmeal I'm
glad you guys warned me though because
it's not as bad as if I just drank it or
like what is this but because you said
it was so bad now is that you not that
bad and you gotta try to keep track at
local stuff okay straw bully let me see
this guy look at this guy look at that
oh I don't think I would order this
again but it's okay good to try the
local stuff
universes Teemo
but you find a penny Lucky Penny Make A
Wish make a wish hope it comes true Nina
wants to go inside Lululemon so here we
go
[Music]
Hayden wants to cool off and went to
cool off in the Miami Heat with some
water you feel better yeah look at this
bag it's a bag with a skateboard on the
first scooter on the bottom whatever's
he can push I like it I see a beach up
ahead
okay next we're gonna hit up Ocean Drive
famous street again here in Miami Beach
and explore some shops and eventually
hit up the beach and get an umbrella and
relax for her that is a big chocolate
milk
Wow Annina gets cappuccino
painten's got his pancakes and bacon
boo-boo and Nina we've got look at that
omelet YUM best bacon ever never had
better bacon alright guys come to Miami
and hit up oceans 10 South Beach place
is good Hayden approved to thumbs-up
night for thumbs up the toes are funny
enough to Hayden is collecting Hayden's
collecting seashells oh look at that
oh that's a piece of plastic that looks
cold let's go
okay jump in
that's it are you done alright too cold
too cold
good job Hayden had fun in the water
we're gonna start heading back Nina's
not feeling that well good a little
nauseous
maybe a little post post Cruz she likes
Dale so we're going to see if our hotel
room is ready can head back maybe pick
up some snacks at Whole Foods no yes yes
[Music]
all right we're here that's like a guest
bathroom there you go that's the
bathroom
[Music]
now the real test do we have CNN okay
let's see Nina let's see do we have CNN
scroll down this is it no number 16 we
have CNN were fishing on vacation yeah
we're on vacation we have CNN I like the
TV that is baked into the mirror here in
the bathroom Charles Barkley dropping
some love
so we relax a little bit gonna hit the
Whole Foods get some snacks maybe some
of the food and what Nina's upset
because they haven't got our luggage up
yet and her phone is out of battery the
good news is my phone still has battery
[Music]
Nina found the alcohol
she found the yucca remember you got to
finish it tonight Nina not really a
little tiny bit but not really
this place has a oh that's called
virtual bowling yeah we can play this
let's go believe nation I lost the game
of foosball I scored on my own net
[Music]
though there's a full table in there we
have ping-pong up there if you want to
play some ping-pong
we've got a movie theater in here
foosball air hockey let's play some
ping-pong
all right let's sit what's next I vote
the table air hockey
and let's go to the pool nice look at
that a beautiful
[Music]
I think this has been the warmest pool
you ever been in the warmest pool
congratulations to this ya hotel for
having a warm room
thumbs up to the JW Marriott in Miami
alright we made it back into the room
have a little bit of time before heading
out for dinner and so I'm gonna film
some more and spresso videos for you
guys so I'm filming my aunt's press
shows for the channel and Nina went and
made me an e Li coffee so that I could
actually be drinking some espresso Thank
You Nina
we love you isn't it fantastic to have
people who support you on your work
we love you Nina you have in your own -
oh I get two options decaf and regular
cab all right is a shot of an espresso
decaf a regular cat extra cash alright
just finished a whole bunch of expresso
filling Hayden got to join a not one of
them that was awesome what do you say to
somebody who says hey how come you have
different colored socks on what because
I'm different because you're different
and you're awesome I love it the wife
and you even got to listen to me yelling
and freaking out I got a little animated
very happy with myself
hopefully it's straight fire for you
guys we'll see otherwise it's just me
yelling but hopefully I think I'm pretty
hungry pretty happy with it but that
Miami expressos let me know when they
come out we are going to head to dinner
local place called Luke's Lobster but a
10 minute walk from where we are Nina
walks Lipton light she's not feeling
super well needs a some like food and
Hayden is just famished and just said he
wants lobster like crazy that's all he
wants to eat right now no no
and I might have made that up but we're
still gonna have fun and eat some Luke's
Lobster
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we found our way to Luke's
Lobster
[Music]
so this is a local Miami beer loud hooby
I give it a shot Nina not a fan
things got ships and we got some water
how's this something vinegar okay how's
this something vinegar very vinegary
very vinegary look at that face how much
vinegar is on there lots of vinegar all
right I'm gonna be myself
whew shimmy lobster crab times - okay
well you get to taste everything try it
oh don't spill it how is it yummy how's
it Nina
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right belief nation coming up on
midnight add another full day thank you
for joining us tomorrow is our last day
I'm gonna wake up hit up little Savannah
little Savannah Little Havana that
little Savannah thank you guys for
joining us we believe in you
continue to believe and whatever your
one or is much love we will see you
tomorrow
[Music]